Las Vegas police made a significant
change in the timeline of the music
festival massacre
investigators say Steven paddock shot a
hotel security guard at 9:59 p.m. that
is six minutes before he opened fire on
the festival and killed 58 people Jamie
yuccas is near the location of the
shooting in Las Vegas with new details
on the gunman Jamie good morning good
morning Clark County Sheriff Joseph
Lombardo says he's frustrated there is
no clear motive yet investigators are
interviewing Steven paddocks brother
Eric here in Las Vegas
they are also requesting his girlfriend
Mary Lou Dan Lee Lombardo calls both of
them key pieces to a very large
investigative puzzle the timeline
associated with the original shot and
mr. Campos has changed Sheriff Joseph
Lombardo says security guard hey-zeus
Campos was initially on the 32nd floor
to check on a suspicious open door down
the hall from Steven paddocks room
investigators believe paddocks saw
Campos on the surveillance he set up
panicked fired on Campos through the
door hitting him in the leg six minutes
before paddock unleashed his deadly
assault he was injured prior to the mass
volley of shooting investigators have
traced some of the killer's movements we
have uncovered over 200 instances of the
suspects traveling throughout Las Vegas
and he has never been seen with anyone
else according to a 97 page court
deposition obtained by CNN Panik took
valium for anxiety and always wore black
sweatpants he acknowledged he gambled
all night and slept all day sometimes
wagering up to a million dollars per
Vinge
at one point paddock boasted about being
the biggest video poker player in the
world the deposition stems from this
2011 incident at the Cosmopolitan Hotel
in which paddock slipped and fell and
later sued over his injuries Chris
Curtis is the security consultant he
says managers need to always test their
procedures sometimes they need to sneak
up leave a door open and see how long it
takes for their security team to see
that a door was not secured
the sheriff says Patek also had
explosives in his car he was targeting
aviation fuel tanks and he had plenty of
body gear as part of an escape plan
authorities are now looking into seeing
if paddock went to an informal shooting
range just two days before the attack to
practice shooting Norah tomorrow Jamie
thank you so much